So here, I've been using just numbers as
the values, but the values can actually be anything
we want. They can even be other dictionaries. So
if you wanted to make more interesting version of
elements. So we'll start with an empty dictionary, and we
can add a new element. This time we'll use the atomic symbol as
the key, and we'll make the value of the element a dictionary that
provides some information about it. So we've added an
element to our dictionary. The key is the single
letter H, and it has as its value a
dictionary, that has three entries with the key name
number and weight. And values associated with each of
those that could be different types. Name is a
string, which gives the full name of the element.
We'll add another element to our dictionary, and so for
helium, we have the same name, number and weight keys,
and, so for helium we have an extra entry that
says it's a noble gas, and the value of noble
gas is true. So now we can look up the
element H, we'll see it's entry. Again note that it's
a dictionary, so the order is not the same as
the order that we used here. But we can do
another lookup. So now we're looking up element H, that gets
us the dictionary here. And then we're looking up in that
dictionary the value name, and that will give us the name
of the element, whose symbol is H. We can change this
to look up some other property. Let's look at the weight.
And we can change element to look up the
value for helium instead of for hydrogen. And now
we get the 4.002, which was the weight of
helium. If we look up the noble gas property,
we get true for helium. What's going to happen if we look it up for hydrogen?
So here we get an error, and we get the same
error that we got before when we tried to look lithium
up in the elements that didn't include lithium as a key.
We are looking for the key noble gas, but it doesn't exist.